hey hey hey wenn ihr möglichst schnell
und einfach abnehmen wollte dann habe
ich jetzt die ultimative diät für euch
ist einfach nur 30 tage lang
ausschließlich lebensmittel essen die
mit vokalen beginnen also zum beispiel
einen apfel oder energydrinks oder
einfach alle bürger dass sie dann die
wichtigsten nährstoffe für dein körper
fehlen egal hauptsache du bist du okay
eine sehr berüchtigte studie hat gezeigt
dass 95 prozent aller diäten scheitern
das soll heißen nur fünf prozent
schaffen es ihr verlorenes gewicht auch
zu halten in meinem letzten video habe
ich aber ja darüber gesprochen wie ich
innerhalb von acht monaten knapp 18
kilogramm abgenommen habe und bisher ist
diese diät auch nachhaltig heißt das
dass ich zu den glücklichen 5 prozent
gehöre und das hat nichts damit zu tun
dass ich die eine besondere diät
gefunden hätte es hat damit zu tun dass
ich gar keine diät gemacht habe das
problem ist die funktionieren
das ist hier in diesem montag
[Musik]
germans bei den domberg canary
stadtgalerie statur bern
was ist überhaupt eine diät eigentlich
bedeutet das wort lebensweise und auch
im englischen heißt david oft einfach
nur ernährung im laufe des 20 und 21
jahrhunderts wurde die diät im deutschen
aber ein synonym für etwas ganz anderes
eine qual die man über einen bestimmten
zeitraum über sich ergehen lässt um
abzunehmen ich zwinge mich bestimmte
dinge nicht zu essen auch wenn die
routinen durchzuziehen und arbeite gegen
die impulse meines körpers aber alles
natürlich nur so kurz wie möglich bis
ich mein wunschgewicht erreicht habe und
die industrie rund um dieses ganze thema
ist super erfolgreich jede woche hat
irgendein klatschmagazin den nächsten
diät geheimtipp der dieses mal ganz
sicher funktioniert oder ich finde auf
instagram wunderpillen die man
garantiert nachhaltigen gewichtsverlust
bringen und mich nicht einfach nur alle
zwei stunden auf die toilette schicken
all dieser quatsch funktioniert
zumindest wirtschaftlich aus zwei
gründen erstens weil super viele leute
gerne dünner wehren und zweitens weil
die zehn diäten die man davor probiert
hat alle nicht geklappt haben deswegen
suchen menschen händeringend nach der
einen methode die endlich funktioniert
und sie super unkompliziert und schnell
zum traumgewicht bringt aber leider
klappt das in der praxis nicht immer
ganz so leicht und dass 95 prozent aller
diäten scheitern ist angeblich sogar
wissenschaftlich belegt egal mit welcher
ernährung mit welchem trainingsplan oder
welcher diät man sich auseinandersetzt
irgendwann landet man immer wieder hier
diese studie findet man auch in super
vielen artikeln die alle effektiv das
gleiche nachplappern die ganze qualen
einer diät bringt gar nichts und früher
oder später werde ich wahrscheinlich
sogar noch mehr als vor der diät aber
irgendwie hat sich fast niemand diese
studie michael hauer angeschaut also
lasst uns das tun und mal
wissenschaftlich analysieren was da
tatsächlich erforscht wurde aber vorher
ganz kurz ein wort vom sponsor des
heutigen videos und das ist vieles die
nummer 111 km in den letzten wochen
haben wir schon öfter über das tracking
von ernährung oder auch von finanzen
gesprochen und eine sache auf die ich
jeden tag achte ist wie glücklich ich
bin glück hat oft mit denkt aber auch
mit verhaltensmustern zu aber wenn ihr
schon mal probiert hat aus alten
vielleicht sogar ungesunden mustern
auszubrechen dann wisst ihr das kann
ganz schön hart sein und genau hier
kommt die familie sap ins spiel stabiles
hilft euch dabei ein auf euch
personalisierte routine zu erstellen und
damit am ball zu bleiben in der app
findet ihr übungen für meditation für
produktivität und vieles vieles mehr und
das ganze beruht auf erkenntnissen auf
der verhaltens wissenschaft und liefert
euch so coaching um euch zu motivieren
und neue routinen zu entwickeln also zum
beispiel mehr zeit für euch mehr wasser
trinken meditation oder mehr sport
machen alles mögliche was auch immer ihr
machen wollte mit fabrice kannst du
jetzt deine ideale tagesroutine starten
und das coole ist die ersten 100 leute
die unten in der regel beschreibung auf
den link klicken erhalten 25 prozent auf
ein premium stereo lissabon hier kannst
du unbegrenzt viele routinen einrichten
und bekommt sogar einen speziell
hoffentlich zugerichtet ist programm für
deine ziele übrigens allein schon die
erst mal runter zu laden lohnt sich mega
bei mir gab es zum einstieg erst mal
eine beruhigende atemübung bevor es
überhaupt weitergehen das fand ich sehr
sehr cool vielen dank an vettel ist dass
sie dieses video hier unterstützen und
genau damit gibt es jetzt auch weiter
die berühmte 95% studie kommt aus dem
jahr 1959 und wurde mit 100
teilnehmerinnen und teilnehmern
durchgeführt also als erstes fällt auf
die studie ist überhaupt nicht aktuell
und die anzahl der versuchsteilnehmer
sehr klein aber vielleicht ist ja dafür
sehr gut durchgeführt und damit super
repräsentativ das würde bedeuten dass
die ergebnisse der studie uns helfen
könnten diäten und ihren erfolg
gesamtgesellschaftlich zu bewerten aber
leider nein die teilnehmerinnen und
teilnehmer waren menschen die ich schon
wegen ihres gewichts oder ihre ernährung
in einer klinischen oder
forschungsorientierten behandlung waren
eine bedeutende mehrheit von ihnen wegen
adipositas also krankhaftem übergewicht
das wirft natürlich die frage auf wie
repräsentativ ist das für uns als
gesellschaft für menschen die vielleicht
einfach nur fünf oder zehn kilogramm
abnehmen wollen vermutlich nicht
wirklich vor allem weil menschen mit
krankhaftem übergewicht das
wahrscheinlich am schwersten haben ihre
ernährung umzustellen
wo die echte zahl der diäten die
scheitern oder klappen liegt das kann
man übrigens auch gar nicht so einfach
sagen denn
wie will man das eigentlich messen ab
wann ist eine diät wirklich erfolgreich
wenn man sein wunschgewicht genau hält
das war tatsächlich das erfolgskriterium
der studie aus 1959 dass man merkt er
diät nichts mehr zu merken kein bisschen
und dann sind wahrscheinlich 100 prozent
aller diäten ein misserfolg denn es ist
absolut normal sich gewichts technisch
in einem gewissen bereich zu bewegen
natürlich kein jojo effekt aber ein bis
zwei kilogramm schwankungen das total
normal die studie wird also von vielen
falsch verstanden hat quasi keine
aussagekraft für die gesamte
gesellschaft und ist zudem über 60 jahre
alt trotzdem gibt es ja auch immer
wieder moderne studien die versuchen die
erfolgsquote von diäten zu messen und
auch wenn man sich jetzt natürlich
darüber streiten könnte auf das
überhaupt möglich ist kommen da ähnlich
ernüchternde zahlen bei rum und auch bei
mir aus dem persönlichen umfeld kenne
ich das viele versuchen ist mit einer
diät und scheitern daran aber woran
liegt das nun jetzt komme ich hier mit
einer grandiosen neuen idee daher
anstatt sich zu fragen warum und wie oft
diäten scheitern wird es vielleicht zeit
dass man einfach mal das ganze prinzip
einer diät hinterfragt lasst mich das
erklären jede diät benutzt eigentlich
das exakt gleiche physikalische prinzip
nur anders verpackt esse ich weniger als
ich verbrenne dann nehme ich ab bis auf
ernstzunehmende krankheiten oder
amputation gibt es keinen anderen weg
für unseren körper gewicht zu verlieren
low carb oder palio ich verzichte auf
bestimmte lebensmittel gruppen und esse
dadurch insgesamt weniger kalorien als
ich verbrenne eine saft chur dadurch
dass ich quasi nur wasser und etwas
zucker zu mir nehme nehme ich weniger
kalorien zu mir als ich verbrenne eine
ice diät bei der ich nur eis essen darf
gibt es tatsächlich aber nach drei
bechern habe ich wahrscheinlich für den
ganzen tag mehr als genug um mir
schlecht ergo ich esse nichts mehr und
nehme ab die einzige ausnahme hierbei
ist wahrscheinlich quito hierbei handelt
es sich aber nicht wirklich um eine diät
sondern um eine therapie die menschen
mit stoffwechselkrankheiten oder
mehreren krankheiten verschrieben wird
also nichts was man ohne ärztliche
anordnung machen sollte denn für gesunde
menschen kann die kette ernährung
ungesund sein aber ihr seht man kann es
lokal oder saft diät oder was auch immer
nennen eines ist immer gleich und muss
es auch sein ich nehme weniger energie
zu mir als mein körper verbrennt und
wenn das das grundprinzip ist dann kann
ich auch eigentlich direkt kalorien
zählen für mich zumindest das gibt einem
einen sehr akkuraten zahlen basierten
überblick darüber wie viele schon
gegessen habe und was ich noch essen
kann und es schränkt mich nicht darin
ein was ich esse aber gut das ist nicht
für jeden etwas das sich auch ein vielen
menschen hilft es natürlich klare regeln
im ernährungsplan zu haben kalorien
zählen ist eben etwas umständlicher als
direkt nur noch flüssigkeiten zu sich zu
nehmen oder auf brot und pasta zu
verzichten aber die verpackung von
kalorien zählen im neue wunder diäten
hat einen entscheidenden nachteil diäten
unterscheiden im gegensatz zu kalorien
zwischen gutem und schlechtem essen
erlaubt und verboten kalorienzählen
zwingt mich nicht grundsätzlich auf
pizza zu verzichten und dann
wahrscheinlich tradings nach pizza zu
bekommen pizza denn am ende ist alles
energie egal ob kohlenhydrate proteine
oder fett das heißt also nicht dass ich
auch schokolade pommes oder eis
verzichten muss mit meinem fall habe ich
nach mehreren monaten kalorien zählen
gar nicht das verlangen nach pizza
gehabt weil ich die ganze zeit schon
pizza essen konnte pizza übrigens wie
die acht monate kalorien zählen bei mir
funktioniert haben das könnt ihr euch
hier anschauen
okay was heißt dass sie alles klappen
diäten oder nicht nun das kommt darauf
an was wir als diät verstehen eine diät
als möglichst kurze intensive
umstellungen kann oft langfristig nicht
durchgezogen werden das heißt irgendwann
kehre ich wieder zu alten mustern zurück
und bin dann auch irgendwann wieder bei
meinem start gewicht und das kennt man
dann als bio effekt wenn man diät aber
eher als ernährung versteht also so wie
das englische digit dann sieht das schon
anders aus eine langfristige
ernährungsumstellung bei der ich
bewusster essen geht zwar nicht
ansatzweise so schnell wie eine saft
diät aber das ist auch gut so so kann
ich mich langsam meinem ideal gerichten
ja und ändere langfristig mein
essverhalten und das klappt rein
physikalisch bei jedem so lange man
weitermacht egal wie alt man ist und
egal wo man ist die einzige
individualität beim abnehmen kommt durch
den stoffwechsel jeder mensch hat eine
fähigkeit aus nährstoffen energie zu
gewinnen eine art effizienz wie energie
umgesetzt wird je mehr wärme dabei
entsteht desto weniger landet als
kalorien auf meinen hüften das ist der
stoffwechsel und der führt dazu dass
jemand mit der gleichen ernährung etwas
langsamer oder eben etwas schneller ab
oder zunehmen kann aber wie schnell das
wird oft überbewertet in der
wissenschaft rechnet man somit circa
zehn bis 15 prozent schwankungen von
mensch zu mensch und damit kommen wir zu
einem anderen wichtigen punkt körper
sind vielfältig und unterschiedlich in
der art wie sie die energie die wir
ihnen geben nutzen ach ja und ich muss
natürlich dazu sagen niemand muss dünn
sein solange ihr euch in eurer haut
wohlfühlt und keine gesundheitlichen
einschränkungen habt ist alles in
ordnung die beste und gesündeste
ernährung ist die die ich für den rest
meines lebens bewusst beibehalten kann
wenn ich nur durch regelmäßige
zitronensaft und gemüsebrühe diäten man
persönlich empfunden das ideal halten
kann dann ist das vielleicht gar nicht
so ideal für meinen körper direkt fürs
zuschauen die letzten beiden videos
waren echte herzens themen von uns und
haben wirklich spaß gemacht abonniert
gern in den kanal wenn ihr mehr solche
sachen sehen wollte und dann sonst immer
vielen dank fürs zuschauen und bleibt
neugierig
kalorien zählen ist eben etwas
umständlicher man braucht eine waage und
es vielleicht einfacher einfach alle
flüssigkeiten nur noch flüssigkeiten zu
nehmen